the clean cold waters of scotland's west
coast perfect conditions for seaweed and
peter elborn is growing it on ropes
below the surface
get to january the light comes back the
nutrients and the water come back
everything is there ready for these
series to start growing really fast
centimeters a day
by may when the seaweed is harvested to
use in food products it'll be two meters
tall and that growth helps mitigate
climate change as seaweed grows it's
absorbing oceanic carbon this year we
would expect it to be
a relatively modest scale rat at the
moment so perhaps around a half a tonne
of carbon dioxide equivalent that we're
absorbing from the ocean
by some estimates seaweed soaks up five
times as much carbon as the same area of
forest assessments of wild kelp suggest
it absorbs more than 200 million tons of
carbon globally when we talk about
capturing carbon we often think about
planting trees but trees take space on
land land that has a myriad of other
uses out here there's no such
competition the seaweed here provides a
habitat for fish and it cleans up the
water it is a win-win for the
environment
but the environmental benefits are a
happy coincidence the driver for farming
is seaweed's growing range of uses in
its urban lab oceanium can extract
protein fiber and minerals it's making a
compostable bioplastic for packaging and
in future seaweed could even replace oil
as a source of building blocks for the
chemical industry you've got very cold
habitats very hot habitats you've got
some quite extreme environments and
seaweed is occupies all of those niches
so it solved a lot of
chemical and physical problems to
survive and that creates a diversity of
chemistry and products that we can use
and develop into things that solve our
problems which is a i think called asco
ask a phylum the scottish association
for marine science is setting up a
seaweed academy to support the fledgling
farming industry it sees huge potential
at the moment seaweed cultivation sits
at
30 million tonnes a year is produced
that's wet wet
and what yeah what
europe wants to do and other countries
in europe wants to do is double that by
2050. it's a new developing industry for
us and i think it's one that yeah we
have to be involved with seaweed farming
doesn't let us off making huge
reductions to greenhouse gas emissions
but the carbon it captures could help
the world reach net zero
thomas more sky news in urban